[Music]
Hello, this
is Yongwook Choi, presenting on the topic of Dino, the next-generation JavaScript runtime.
[Applause]
I am
working as a developer experience engineer at Lead, and I
am making various development trims used in the company, such as TV key and wrp, for dinner. Also, here in
front of me.  This friend of mine
is a dino character, so
dinos are cute, so I'm
contributing to the dinner ecosystem in a small way. If you have any
questions about this story or just
want to view it, I have a feather and
Twitter account, so please
follow me here and I'll probably sell it.  Let
's start by
looking at the situation of creating a project using Dino and TyScript to
find out what problems there are and
tell you how Dinner solves those problems.
Next, I will
explain Dino's improved developer experience.  Actually, I wanted to
write that this is an incomparable developer experience.
That's one
of the biggest advantages of Dino over Node js.
Also, today I will only
explain Dino, but now Node js also has a
really large ecosystem, and Egger that
runs on Node js
Since there are so many seeds, we
need to be able to use this ecosystem well. So, let's
look at how to ensure compatibility with Node js while using Dino.
Lastly, I would like to share a little about how our team used Dino.
Now, let's consider the situation of creating a Node JS project with TypeScript.
First of all, in order to use many libraries in the JavaScript ecosystem, you
will need a package manager. Here, there
is MPM Yan Yangberry,
pmpm, and
one of the package managers like this.
Then, in
order to match the code quality and style,
I have to choose various tooling such as ES Link or Free Tier.
Also, if there are any
plugins, compics, or rules that I want, I
can add them and adjust the settings.
After doing this, we
need to add casting libraries to improve the quad quality a little more. I
selected chat libraries such as Zest, Mocha, or the recently released Btest and
set up the project.
But it doesn't end here. Now, the
TyScript code is Node js.
Since you can't run it right away, you now
need transpiler settings.
Now you can use
it to convert the Javastick code and then pass it back to Node js,
or you can use a transpiler like TS Node
Scrase SWC as a
tire script
compiler, or  Now,
when Nodejs loads the Timesquake model through a register hook, it is already
passed as a JavaScript transpiler, so you
can run a test script on NodeJS. I
created a simple Nodejs project, but there
seem to be a lot of things to consider.  Wouldn't it be
possible to run the project faster and more simply? It
would be nice to be able to write modern stick code without having to do all this work.
So, I would like to introduce you to Dino, a
new JavaScript runtime that will solve this problem.
These problems
can be easily solved by using Dinner.
First,
since Dino does not use a package manager, there is
no need to choose a package manager.
External modules are imported through URL and
packages
are stored in the local cache.  You
can use it without setting up.
There are also these advantages, but this time I
will explain more about Dinner's improved developer experience. I have
listed several advantages that I think are significant from the developer experience perspective. I will introduce them one by one.
First of all, there is a
rich and well-selected standard library that can be used in a variety of situations.
Representative modules include ASync Bytes IU Strings
HTP. Let me
introduce them one by one briefly.
Async provides various utility functions that can be created with promises.  It
contains
functions that can handle things like debounce, default delay, etc. You no longer need to implement npm insta or various non-dives that you can often use when creating a project.
Aion is
Dino's leader and writer.  It
provides a buffer that can be used in the interface.
If you
want to distinguish between objects in the interface course that reads and writes certain data, you
can get a lot of help from this IO library and IO module by implementing it in line with Dino's leader and Lightning interface.
Streams
provides buffers and UT functions for the Web Streams API.
And http makes it
easy to create an http server,
and now
also provides functions related to http errors, status codes, and cookies.
In Node JS, these Dino  There is a
built-in module that corresponds to the standard library, but
this built-in model is
not a separate version and is simply simplified with the runtime of Node js, so it has
the disadvantage of not being able to easily upgrade the version. For
example,
in a project that was using Node 11, today it is 14.
When you want to upgrade to version 16, there are
many cases where the code does not work even though the version has been updated. There
are situations where it is not easy to change the Node Jason version. As I
mentioned earlier, the version of the built-in module is also fixed depending on the runtime version.
It is difficult to use new features. The
standard library has separate versions from the runtime.
In this situation, you
can flexibly fix the version of the runtime while adjusting the version of the standard library. It is
distributed the same as other third-part libraries and imported in the
same way.  Therefore, as
shown earlier, you can easily update by
simply uploading the version to the loaded library.
Next, Dino provides a Promise-based
asynchronous API.
Many of the asynchronous APIs provided were
written before the advent of Promise.  So, the
main logic still uses the callback method.
So,
in order to use it in the form of a promise, you can
use the foliage file in the built-in module called Yotil and
change the connection method to return a promise, or use a FS
promise like a promise.  There is
no choice but to use APIs that have been reprocessed to visit Promise.
Dino has all these
starter APIs
written based on Promise,
so it does not provide a callback-style API at all.
Each has a lead file function implementation. It
receives a callback and
receives a codec.  We
create a context called the second lead file context and
execute the callback by passing the Corvette context to the internal binding in the last line.
In contrast, the dino on the right has a
read file
function configured as an h-class function from the beginning.  You can see that the basic logic is configured by using Aways to
call the internal API of the external cost machine as shown below.
Even if you look at Old Testament Rosema and
Old Rose Network earlier, you
can see that the dinner code is a little cleaner. This
node js's fs
In order to change the lead file function in the Promise type,
more code goes into Node js.
All of this code goes into it.
So
in Dino, just the
section on the right in front of you already
creates an API that wants that state.  That's
over, but now
this much code goes into Node. It would be
nice if that didn't happen again, but
if you ever need to look into the internal implementation, for
example, if you step on a bug and have to
look into the external system, you'll have to choose
between the two runtimes.  It
will be easier for Dino to view the internal sections.
Dinner's standard library
has a cleaner internal implementation. As
explained earlier, there
is no significant difference in the way the existing standard library is provided compared to other third-part libraries, so this is all.
It's a bit obvious, but the
fact that the functions of the standard library that are mainly used when writing Dino code are clean inside the code is
very helpful when debugging or understanding the internal operation.
Next, Dino uses the web platform API, and the platform
API uses
Chrome or Firefox.  This refers to web APIs built into the same browser.
When implementing various functions in a runtime outside the browser, the
same functions are often already installed within the browser. In
this case, Dino provides a
web API that is compatible with the browser without reinventing the wheel.
By implementing ,
browser wire interoperability is ensured. The
same
web APIs are already implemented in Dino.
Of course, some of these web APIs are implemented in Node JS,
but
most of the functions are experimental, so only
some are compatible or
external libraries must be used.  Even
if it is amplified, it now exists in the form of an internal module, so you need to
call up the square mode to use it. Since
these APIs used in the browser
can be used directly in Dinner,
even those who mainly write browser API code can
easily use the browser Bark runtime on Dino.  You
can write code that runs in. If you
search for web APIs such as local storage in mdn like below, you
can see that Dinner is in the compatibility table at the bottom of the document.
Next,
what are the various npm packages we use?  It can become malicious code due to various issues. In
this case,
Nodejs has a structure that makes it difficult to respond to this malicious code
manipulating the system.
In the fund, appropriate permissions are required when access to the file system or network
environment variables is required.  You
can avoid these problems because you can prevent this from running in case you don't have one.
Another thing I like
is that it only supports ES modules with the module system.
Commonges AMD what
ES modules these
multiple module systems.  I think these
things are now a bit of a big barrier to entry when learning JavaScript for the first time, but
because Dino only supports ESM, it is possible to write code without thinking about these old module systems. Not only that,
but as
introduced earlier, there are now a ton of  The
standard library, which contains a huge number of functions, is also written as an ES module, so it is
easy to read the internal code regardless of JavaScript proficiency. We have
explained what advantages Dino has so far and why it is better compared to RoadJS.
However, no matter how good it is, it would be
even better if you can use the vast ecosystem of Node JS. So,
in this article, I will
introduce a way to
run each other's code in reverse time. There are several ways to run Node JS code in Dino.  If you
start with how to execute small code fragments,
small
code fragments that were previously executed in Node js can now be
secured by replacing them with node-compatible modules within the Dino standard library. Although
not all features are supported yet.
As you can see on the right, most
modules are compatible, and we are
now expanding this
compatibility by focusing on well-known libraries. Not only
small pieces of code, but
also the entire code written for Node Jace
can be easily run.
Dino  There is a node computability mode, which
allows you to use various global objects and common js. It
also automatically fills in the polypy without having to change the Roadzenis APIs to
node-compatible modules in Dino's standard library, which were explained earlier.
Compatibility model  To use it, you
can use DinoRun's Compaq flag to change the overall execution environment to compatibility mode.
In this way, the Commonsing Hills code is internally processed by
creating a wrapper around it and evaluating the entire code, as shown
below.  Many
things are omitted, but when
special variables of the commons, such as the Pyname used on the left, or
now dedicated modules such as processes
execute the code on the right, you can see that
all the special things are filled in in the special parts of these nodes.
Sometimes  There may be cases where you want to use these large MPM modules by
importing them in biner code. In
this case, if
you use a dino-friendly cdnd, you
can use node JS modules without any hassle.
Dino-friendly cds include
esm-h or skypack.  If you
receive a module from this cdn, you
will be able to use the mode with the things that node computerability mode used to do done automatically.
Now, the cdn
automatically converts commonality-based code to esm in advance, and
typing for type street is also provided.
It provides
various Node js built-in modes by
replacing them with std node polyfills.
So,
if you import like this as shown below, you
can automatically receive a changed MPM module that can be used in Dino.
Previously, Node Computability mode and
Dino-friendly  We introduced how to use cdn to
ensure compatibility with npm modules.
In fact,
starting with Dino 1.25.2, the
node computability mode has been deleted and
npm modules have been
imported using a new method called npm special fire. The
new npm specification  Using Fire, you
no longer need to change the entire execution environment using special flags like Node Compaq mode, and you
can use mpa mode without relying on the Gino-friendly cdn. It is
also simpler to use than before.
Dinner-friendly  Just as cdn had to
add an address like esm.sh in front of the import path,
now you just need to add the npm
prefix to the npm colon.
After doing DinoRun like below, a
strange cow called Kaosei comes out and
talks to you.
Now you can see that the MPM
mode has been executed directly through DinoRun. The
compatibility information we have found out so far is
related to compatibility at the code level. The
RoadJS ecosystem consists of
codes that use NodeJS's API.  However,
add-ons also exist.
Add-ons written in low-level languages
manipulate JavaScript values ​​using the Node API, which is built by Nodes,
so
compatibility with the Node API must be provided to
enable the add-on to be loaded and used at other times.  A
PR that takes care of compatibility with these node APIs is currently in progress, so
if this PR is applied,
SK Lite that uses add-ons among the various SK Lites in npm or
friends such as Sharp, an image processing library, will be able to use them in Dinobee.
Until now, the
method was to execute Node js by starting the code, but now,
on the contrary, there
is a way to run a library written in Dino in Node js. Now, there is a
Dino node transform conversion
library called dmt, so you can
only use a small conversion code using dnt.  If you write it, you
can change it to code.
dmt now injects the power to run various resources with space that created the import identifier of the module in
Nodejs. The
code on the left is the conversion code using flight t.
Currently, it is from the top.  From the top, we
create a directory called npm and now
write a build script that configures the package targeting that directory. Change the modules
one by one based on the entry point in this bid street and
fill in the contents to be included in package Jason as shown below.
Although it is not shown in the example, it is
also possible to specify a specific dependency and a specific Dino dependency to a specific npm model. If the
node code for the original code has been created in advance, you
can use the node code instead of the Dino code you are currently using.  You can make it possible.
If there is no dependency on the API,
that is, you
use the Dinner standard library or external libraries, but those
libraries do not directly use the Dino API, there
is no need to use dmc.
ES Build and ES Build Dino Loader
plugins  You can
easily bundle Dino code
using yesbs.
YesBs also have a separate Dino wrapper,
so you
can easily write bundling code using espied on GinoScript just as if you were writing code that changes using dnt.  The
example is now code that bundles sata1 code from Dino's standard
library
through Yes build.
Lastly, we would like to
share our experience of using Dino to create development tooling that works in the Node JS ecosystem using this node compatibility.
Our team  I
created a development tooling called pbqg. This is an
adventure in development tuning related to the ibKiz protocol buffer.
Even though it has to be provided for various runtimes such as browsers, I
was able to create Nodesy tooling without losing the developer experience by using soap.
All codes in the pbq main repository.
Although it is written in Gino,
there are three parts that need to be considered for compatibility. It can be
seen in Dinocore, Titicore, PBT, Codegen, and Proto language.
Because the conditions for each are different, we
had no choice but to proceed with code conversion in different ways. We would like to introduce them one by one,
npm.  It has no dependency on
Dino and was intentionally
written to have no dependency on Dino
because this code
needs to be made easy to run on the browser, but if
there is a dependency on a specific band, it is
difficult to change it in the process. The
pbq core has no dependency like this.  I
was able to make it executable on the browser by simply removing the file extension from the
import statement. Of course, the process of converting the test report to JavaScript
now uses the core code, so the conversion process must be done
in the user's workflow of the client developer.  The
codegen part now needed to be bundled into a single file. In
this
case,
using esbied and esbied dinoloader
was a possible method because there was no dependency resolution problem and there was no dependency on bundling and API.
Next, the protocol buffer we created.  Although the
language server is now
created using an npm package called vs Code Jason rpc, it is
now a bit tricky because it has to run on vs Code, that is, the Node JS runtime.
So
in these more complex cases, lsp with
dino holding is now used as
lst.  Instead, I
made the Dino-specific Productpuff language server code into a single npm module using dnt, and
converted it so that it can now be installed using npm install for the Bethcode plugin.
In these various situations,  We
were able to use Dino without any major issues even in projects that take care of compatibility.
So, finally,
can we use it in Polduction? Our
team
used Dino to create development tooling, and we
were able to easily introduce Dino because there were few npm package acquaintances and situations where it was necessary.
If you develop a part that is dependent on the existing ecosystem, there
will be no problem in introducing Dino into production.
If there is a deep dependency on a specific npn module, check whether that module is used and operating
through the compatibility methods introduced earlier.
However, if
compatibility is not resolved, it would be
nice if you could contribute directly in this case, but now just by listing the
issue related to node compatibility in Dino, the
main canners will work to make it compatible.  There are
some points to consider when using the Node JS ecosystem,
but on the contrary, it is
not very difficult to write code that is compatible with Node JS or the browser in Dino. First of all, since we write the code itself, we
separate dependencies like we did with pbk.  You can fill in any strategy
and easily obtain compatible code by running dmt or espd according to the situation.
So, personally, I don't consider the legacy design philosophies that
can now be used without such complicated settings and the
ecosystem with ecology has spread.  I
think I was able to experience the moment when writing JavaScript code became fun again while developing with Dino, which doesn't need to be used and can get a lot of help from the standard library. You definitely taught me about
production. Even if you start with small
cli tooling or a
blog.  Okay,
but I hope you try writing code with Dino in some form and
have the same heart-pounding experience as I did.
Thank you.
[Applause]